alors justement les 18 candidats qui qui
sont présents on retrouve des têtes
connues avec mon retrouvent le soir et
chimène badi et pas qu'eux et bilal
assadi et qu'on connaît qui est un
célèbre youtuber qui évoluent sur cette
émission cabrita reis qui date en garder
mais valérie ce midi à droite ça suffit
je donnerai migaud voilà voilà
on a voulu saboter les gens très bien
écouter regarder justement bilal assadi
regardez sa performance sa reprise de
aya nakamura
[Musique]
oh
m
et
[Musique]
six mois de plus et ludivine grâce à ma
fille ma fille est facile mais qui fait
bonsoir paris
je sais on va gagner l'eurovision avec
paris j'aime énormément ce petit gars il
a beaucoup de courage aux tories pour
lui non mais je vais c'est pas vous
feriez je voterai pour lui concours de
choses
il chante très bien mais il chante très
bien et surtout il était récemment
malheureusement la victime d'une sévère
campagne de harcèlement de cyber
harcèlement sur twitter et il reste
droit dans ses baskets vraiment fallu
moins de choses et il arrive il fait
très beau ce que tu aimais le prince et
plan alors mais il a du talent du dos